My name is Logan.
I may be able to help you find some answers.
Who am I?
I know how special you are.
I come with you, I'm coming for blood.
Are you ready...
- No law...
...to do what you need to do?
No code of conduct...
Hunt him down.
You want to shoot me, SHOOT ME!
They did to me what I am.
I can't be undone
You are different now. They can hurt you.
A lot of people have tried to kill me. But I'm still here.
You have struggled long enough, Logan.
Right now, I'm feeling unbelievable gratitude
that this part happened to come into my life.
What you have with Wolverine and his back story
and an actor of power of Hugh Jackman playing him
is unique among other superhero films.
Wolverine and Hugh Jackman cannot now be separated.
The man and the role have merged.
He has found a way to connect a deep part of himself to this character.
Ladies and gentlemen, HUGH JACKMAN!
This is going to be my last time I'll be putting on claws. One. Last. Time.
This is what life looks like... Feel it... You still have time.
What's so wonderful about Hugh is that he is hungry to go deeper and darker than he has ever been before.
Because this is Hugh's last movie, as this character, I wanted to make sure NOT that it's his last movie, but that it's his best movie.
And CUT! We got it!
It's a really surreal day. I've got my 16 year old in the trailer, who was not even born when I started playing this part.
No movie has meant more to me than this movie. From the bottom of my heart, thank you so much for helping us realize this dream.
I am grateful to things in a big way
and I consider it a great, great privilege to have had the chance to play this character.